thank you
[Music]
all right let's talk about it y'all
let's talk about the liver King big fat
whoo we love liver King dude there's a
liver King table over here you guys know
the news better than the news
disappointed by that no I was actually
excited oh how come I was ecstatic can I
tell you my because I have a bunch of
different voices in my head can I tell
you what each voice was thinking yeah
stress that eventually so the first one
I was like duh you stupid [ __ ]
like this guy clearly looks like he's
[ __ ] uh is on steroids it's like
super [ __ ] like everybody else
everyone that goes oh he's on steroids
I'm like no [ __ ] he's like seeing
someone that's bald with no eyebrows and
go he doesn't have leukemia no this
[ __ ] has it this feels great
alopecia dude
he went with Luke
and Coke and donuts guys
powder walking with the IV bag you're
like bro you I know what you got you
don't even got to tell me he's great
dude
with liver can't you see him red as [ __ ]
[ __ ] pulsating high blood pressure
vein veins everywhere so that looks like
a roid build right it's like a hundred
percent but then the other part of me
I'm like oh but that's because that's
I'm in the industry so I've seen this so
I can totally see if someone's just a
regular person and seeing it like whoa
this guy's jacked oh wait he eats balls
and he gets this
Buffet you know that's that's the funny
part is that people bought into it I had
a couple clients that would be like hey
man like before like liver King even
blew up to where he was today they'd be
like hey you think Liberty King's on
steroids really he's like he's like he's
like natural right and I was like oh bro
no way
it's insane that people would like I
think certain people that aren't in the
fitness space they're just normal people
think people don't know that the Rock's
on steroids they just don't know you
know they don't just wait the rock is on
steroids yeah so are people upset at
liver King now
um I don't know I'm not I'm not too sure
because for me because I are y'all no
because for me since day one I saw him
as a character in The Fitness space yeah
so it was like watching like Insane
Clown Posse you know it was just like oh
this guy
I don't know where he [ __ ] I don't
know how many voices are in your [ __ ]
head
this dude entertaining character you
know yeah right I was just like this is
the entertaining character and I'm
having fun with what he's doing so do
you so okay so now with that with that
being said like is he eating all that is
eating all the [ __ ] food the way he
really is he eating that that way every
day that's the thing now right the thing
now is if he can lie about this how many
other things is he lying about a
straight face line dude like he was just
straight up like I have never taken I
have never taken away uh emails got
leaked yes
some emails I like I like to hear it
from their perspective because they're
emotional about it well I could tell you
so this is for me
um
I I actually uh admire His World
building because I don't know if it's
true or not but the world that he built
where he's like
um I'm natural I eat testicles I'm about
the ancestral nine tenants this little
shows his bed and it's a [ __ ] palette
yeah and then he has like these curtains
that you met like what no none of this
wavelength comes in and he talks about
how his cell phone is over here and he's
like pulling rocks on his Ranch so it's
like his whole world of how he lives
yeah it was really well constructed yeah
so on my modern day caveman you can't be
mad at it from a marketing point of view
one I don't think people should be mad
at him and the other thing is like I
don't think you needed to lie about it
he did it yeah yeah because they're like
he just talked about how like you know
somebody confronted him on like a
podcast because he was getting notoriety
and fame for what he was saying and
doing and showing and they'd be like you
know do you ever take steroids and then
he would lie about it but the second he
lied about it the second somebody else
would ask another time so he doubled
down on his life and then he he just
felt like he kept on digging himself
into a deeper hole of the line oh okay
and misleading more people especially
since he was also like monetizing off of
like you know whatever culture yeah
because people yeah people were actually
believing that [ __ ] yeah did you guys
watch his apology video because I didn't
watch it yeah was it pretty good it's
pretty funny
does he mean it to be funny all right no
but he's just like saying he he's like I
[ __ ] up I'm ashamed I made a mistake
like he's he's saying all the stuff that
you've kind of would think yeah yeah I
also think he's a genius marketer
because the way he says it
doesn't seem
like I don't have Asperger's but when I
when I I mean maybe I do maybe maybe I
do based on your comparisons though I
don't know
he definitely has leukemia
speaking with someone with Asperger's I
can go I think this guy is sincere or
not and I don't think he was sincere but
I think he knows the words and the way
to like use poetry to get people to go
this guy's such a stand-up guy you know
what I mean yeah yeah so I think people
get caught up in that because he's
already done such a good job of bringing
everyone to like give like if you were
to write this on paper and say this is
the character that I'm gonna build and
he would like ask you like you think
this would work that's the genius part
of it you'd be like no [ __ ] way dude
you're gonna eat like raw balls emails
it discusses that this is what I'm
trying to do I want to build this
character what kind of steroids are you
what else do I need and it he it's
almost as if like before he even posted
his first liver Keen character he spent
like three years of development yeah and
that's the part that I'm like that's
crazy yeah that's true that's a fan I
think I am too bro but that's what I'm
saying for me I don't think it is
watching a real life character the guy's
not doing any [ __ ] harm right but if
you buy into it that's the problem yeah
I mean you wanna wait wait so what what
does he make how does he make his
supplement supplements probably like his
other website well he was a millionaire
prior to even being like famous oh
really yeah because he's always lived on
that ranch right yeah we're gonna do is
selling liver no he sells Supple he has
like a supplement company that has a
bunch of like different like all the
organ meat stuff all the vitamins you
get in Oregon means if you get it in
capsules and stuff like so it's not this
is like the worst thing ever but it's
just the fact of like you know
that that he's lying about doing
steroids I think that's probably the
biggest offense and then they eat like
cow liver raw every single day again
that's what people were doing they were
like copying him because he's not
getting buff as [ __ ] yeah so why was he
why was he able to do it that way and
other people get sick from it
I'm doing the same thing he's doing
right he also has like a private chef
and all that well he might not have even
been doing it that's the thing we don't
know what else he's lying about now that
he's he was lying about steroids people
are like oh you probably weren't doing
any of that [ __ ] yeah was he actually
eating it that's the thing but that's
why I think it kind of helps him like I
think that he now that he admitted he
was lying it sort of opens them up to a
different kind of audience that actually
is entertained by this now yeah I wonder
I wonder if he entertained because one
of his because like he is so good to
stick into his world there's this one
video that I like every single time I
watch his videos I get impressed there's
one he's like at some crazy sweet in at
a Vegas casino yeah and he goes I'll
show you how liver King sleeps and then
so he shows like the hotel room right
and he goes I don't sleep on the bed and
he point and he pans down and it's all
these little mats that he's sleeping on
on the floor and I'm like wow well
because it's that's his character
because it's his tenants are that he
lives the way it came oh he's nailing it
every single time but obviously I'm in
my mind bro like right after this video
you're [ __ ] getting back
but the fact that he can stick to it is
like holy [ __ ] also this probably
elevates him even more because now now
there's this new layer to him now we
found out now we found out he was lying
so now people are oh I'm still invested
right yeah exactly now there's like a
longer story and like even like when he
was on flagrant they were trying to get
him to eat that donut like he wouldn't
do that prior but now that he's like did
he eat the donut that sting like you got
to watch the video now because they just
they just show it like it's like yeah
it's like a thrilling thing and he's
just like it's like he's like
because Schultz is like dude you've been
lied about stories eat that [ __ ]
donut bro it's like now he can do [ __ ]
like that that he wouldn't have access
to that comedy but getting Genius Like
whether it's like Evil Genius or Good
Genius just the fact that he can craft
this world and then after [ __ ] up it
opens the story lines exactly what the
now now he's Ric Flair dude right like
now he might even be richer than he'd
been before now he's a character he's a
professional wrestling character exactly
now it like it took a stardom to a whole
other level and it's like there's so
many my favorite video is him going like
he's like so delivery can do shower and
he goes soap has never touched this box
he was saying like I sat behind this
[ __ ] guy at the weigh-ins and he
smelled like dog [ __ ] doesn't shower at
all dude and I was like dude was he at
the event with no shirt on yeah yeah he
never that's his thing that's another
thing he don't wear shirts you know what
the genius thing is when uh people you
know like the funniest people are are
people that don't know they're funny
yeah right you watch them and like oh
that's just them like that guy is just
that's really him yeah the genius part
is he seems like that but he knows he
has one on you
um that's the genius part where people
think he doesn't know but he knows that
he knows and you don't know who leaked
the emails so it's this guy named
vigorous Steve uh
okay Steve uh that's crazy the liver
game all right yeah yeah he explained
that he only whatever yo who are these
guys what does that even mean in this
context all right guys I'm vigorous
he's a trainer um but he explained that
he only ever trained liver king for a
few weeks and then refunded him the
money he'd spent on why did he backstab
him like that that's [ __ ] up uh it
says why the refund Vigor Steve claims
that liver King was only ever interested
in hiring him as a trainer because he
wanted advice on taking steroids uh the
coach also said he offered liver King
dietary advice noting that all the
influences diet needed a lot of changes
but liver King declined So speaking on
his own YouTube channel vigorous Steve
said that he was the one who gave
YouTube Fitness educator Derek better
known as more no more place more days
permission to expose liver King steroid
use so oh so he broke it yeah oh on
Rogan
I think he broke it on his channel yeah
Steve said I gave Derek permission to
use the emails in a redacted form to
help Brian aka the liver King finally
come clean and end the lies dead in
their chest which to a certain extent he
did he admitted to well he catapulted
his career I think yeah because what do
you think yeah because who who cares
about vigorous Steve now no one never
heard of him and no one even cares that
liver Keen was on steroids like he's
probably more views nobody really cares
yeah like like how do you feel because I
know a lot of Fitness like I follow a
lot of Fitness people and a lot of
Fitness people were like really upset
and they made it like you know he's
Liberty that's just because they want to
talk [ __ ] online they wouldn't say [ __ ]
to his face that's what I'm saying they
would never they would never go up to me
like you know I was really mad about
that I don't know what do you think
about all that well actually I guess we
got your take already you're like I
encourage it well for me I think it's
um there's your industry and then
there's reality right like if you're a
purist obviously you want to see more
guys like GSP yeah Conor McGregor comes
and he like blows the roof off
at the end of the day you're playing you
have to know the room you're playing to
and for like the fitness purists they
really want to go based off science and
all that [ __ ] and then but you have to
understand that's that's literally your
ceiling when you have someone that I
guess lies and that's the sad truth that
might of course that when you lie about
[ __ ] you can go [ __ ] way crazy or if
you're more entertaining or whatever
well it's the character like but he lied
about steroid use yeah yeah and he go
and he even said it he goes like I
wasn't hurting anybody I was I was
hurting myself yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah anything like yeah yeah I guess you
could make the claim of like you know
young children are gonna see you they
talk to you I hate when people say [ __ ]
like that it's like talk to your kids
then talk to your kids thank you you
don't want to have a copy like people
that say that don't have conversation
don't conversations with their kids
steroids yeah yeah well that's the same
thing it's like when we were kids
watching him we knew he was on roads and
he was fighting Commando though yeah I
hear all those superheroes are too yeah
okay Chris Hemsworth he's a [ __ ]
too right on steroids these dudes for
sure on steroids but he's like do my app
right you do my app and you're gonna get
jacked like like Thor and they're doing
nothing but burpees and jumping jacks
you're not gonna look like Chris
Hemsworth doing jumping jacks my boy
like you take the breaker to you yeah
yeah yeah and the people on Biggest
Loser on steroids so they don't look
like that yeah so I have a friend that's
a coach on there I'm not gonna say their
name uh but like to get a dramatized TV
show the biggest the TV show yeah to get
like a really good storyline you need
people that are losing like a hundred
pounds yeah how the [ __ ] are you gonna
do that in one season yeah so to like
win and help the TV you know like the
producers would come I need your client
to take this and a griddle yeah
there's some coaches on there that quit
they're like [ __ ] I can't be doing that
man like this is a it's like the wrong
message or whatever and people commit
suicide after the show yeah or like on
that game right back or like Wolverine
like a Hugh Jackman if he has to be this
Jack for Wolverine and literally in
three months he needs to [ __ ] sing or
some [ __ ] he has to [ __ ] life is rubbed
yeah he has to [ __ ] you know get off
his gear like it's a lot of his name is
like the best name for steroids like
Hugh Jackman that's true yeah
Jean Val Jackson so I mean there's
definitely a layer like uh corruption
and dishonesty that transcends all
Industries I'm inspired but like we're
like you know what I'm saying liver King
in comparison to all that other [ __ ]
like I mean what is he really he's a
hero that's what he is the American
people that [ __ ] is so classic though
it's like what would Tiger King be
without Scandal like yeah
I think he even goes like you know what
this is I've reached like my Plateau
yeah like because that's such a
perfectly formulated leak to get on more
plates more dates because he's the
biggest of He's The Joe Rogan of Fitness
right like he's the one that exposes
scandals and go oh look at Kumar Usman I
think he's been on steroids or this guy
I think he's been on stairs he is the
steroid call-out guy and how
coincidental is it that
he is the one that finds out about him
yeah true so it could have been just a
genius marketing plan that's been built
for like I hope that's what Kim
Kardashian Fitness World favorite liver
King video is I I redact everything I
just said is the video is the video of
hasbula taking a picture with liver King
really and then Haas Bula says and rush
into his handlers he goes I'd rather
take a picture with a dog instead what
what and I feel bad for
the bathroom he's like yeah
yeah like a Russian and then he looks
annoyed he walks away and the liver
King's like what what what's happening
really yeah dude that's a big picture
with dog
said that about me dude I'd be crushed
damn my hero dude he's my liver yeah
yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]